[Música]
não me vou
quero começar hoje contando duas
histórias
a primeira dela dessa máquina aqui
alguém conhece a máquina não é uma
máquina antiga e acho que quando a gente
fala de tecnologia a gente tende a falar
muito de internet das coisas ou debora
bloch em bicões enfim e eu gosto muito
de voltar atrás na história e entender
muitas as tecnologias que foram
importantes para o mundo que a gente
vive hoje e tentar entender qual foi o
impacto delas na verdade olhando agora o
retrospecto que sempre é mais fácil a
gente entender olhando assim essa
máquina ela se chama cotton jim e ela
tem uma funcionalidade que é
relativamente simples que basicamente o
que ela faz é pegar o algodão separar a
semente de algodão da fibra do algodão
antes da lei existir esse processo era
feito manualmente então tinha várias
pessoas sentadas ali tentando né fazer
esse trabalho que é super minucioso
inclusive trabalhoso e demorado enfim e
quando ela surge isso há mais de 200
anos nos estados unidos
toda a produção é extremamente
impactadas por que a gente começa a
conseguir fazer essa separação do
algodão uma maneira mais rápida
consequentemente a forma como produzir
tecidos passa a mudar radicalmente
porque eu consigo fazer isso de um jeito
muito muito muito mais rápido e
eficiente
então muita gente vê essa máquina como
uma das grandes invenções que realmente
mudaram a manufatura mudar um jeito como
as fábricas funcionam e que inclusive
tem um impacto muito grande nos dias de
hoje inclusive então muito dessa
tecnologia é tão simples impactou assim
mesmo 200 anos depois a gente ainda vê
impacto dela e eu acho isso muito
fascinante e a segunda história que eu
quero contar essa aqui que é do meu vôo
que também teve um impacto muito grande
mas obviamente na minha vida mas o meu
avô ele foi o 11º médico do rio grande
do sul então o crm dele era zero
10 11 e ele foi médico numa época que
obviamente não se entendia muito ainda
de medicina muitas das doenças não eram
conhecidas e mesmo trabalhando num
terreno que ainda era tão desconhecido e
que ainda exigia muito na uma busca por
conhecimento e por entendimento ele
sempre foi muito interessado em diversos
outros assuntos sendo um deles a ciência
e ele era casado com a minha avó
a minha avó é extremamente religiosa
sempre que eu estava lá na casa deles
vinha falar comigo sobre adão e eva
sobre como o mundo tinha surgido então
enfim me contava várias histórias
bíblicas e meu avô
depois que eu vou contar essa história
me chamava para ir no jardim que é nesse
exato jardim que está na foto e dizia
bom vem aqui vamos conversar
pegava um livro de stephen hawking e me
falava de buracos negros e então do bebê
e enfim e acho que esse foi meu primeiro
contato com a ciência e acho que eu vou
fazer isso sempre muito itu de tentar me
mostrar diferentes pontos de vista e
também de tentar me fazer sempre olhar
as coisas com um olhar amplo então uma
questão que era muito forte pra ele era
gente sair da nossa vivência individual
e poder tentar tentar entender o mundo
através dos olhos da ciência e não só os
da nossa vivência e aí com esse olhar
ned curioso talvez que eu vou me trouxe
de enxergar tantas coisas diferentes
acho que minha carreira foi muito muito
guiada desse jeito porque na verdade eu
trabalhei com a administração eu me
formei em administração de empresas mas
eu estudei psicologia eu fui a operadora
da bolsa eu trabalhei com o marketing
digital e trabalhei em escolas e fui
gestor de projetos e um dia eu criei uma
ong ano no meio de tudo isso que buscava
aproximar-se dos cidadões né cidadãos da
política e pra isso pela primeira vez eu
comecei a pensar em como a tecnologia
seria poderosa para nos ajudar nesse
desafio
então a gente fez um eu junto né com
todo mundo da ong
a gente fez um quadro fã dele para
tentar conseguir dinheiro para criar uma
plataforma para as eleições municipais
isso foi lá em 2011 e 2012
a gente fez
vanden e uma empresa de tecnologia nos
descobriu então recebi um e-mail dizendo
a vocês podem ver aqui na toca porque
até então eu nunca tinha ouvido falar
sobre falar sobre o projeto de vocês a
gente se interessou enfim e aconteceu é
que as empresas resolveu fazer toda a
plataforma de uma forma pro bono e
poucos meses depois eu acabei indo
trabalhar para essa empresa e parece uma
coisa muito pra mim sou sempre muito
como se eu tivesse caído de paraquedas
nessa área porque era muito diferente
das coisas que já tinha feito e às vezes
eu não entendia muito bem por que minha
vida tinha ido pra esse pra esse rumo
pra esse lado e depois de mais de cinco
anos trabalhando com isso eu passei a me
dar conta de que eu fui trabalhar com
tecnologia para que essa fosse também
essas fossem também as minhas lentes
através das quais eu leio o mundo e se a
gente pensa que a tecnologia tem mudado
e acho que a gente fala muito disso né
de como cada vez mais as mudanças
especialmente as tecnológicas têm uma
velocidade cada vez mais alta um escopo
muito amplo e um impacto sistêmico
isso torna cada vez mais uma leitura de
mundo dentro desse contexto é porque as
coisas estão o tempo inteiro mudando e
não tem perspectiva de que isso em algum
momento desacelera ea tendência é que
seja cada vez mais e mais rápido
e aí acho que quando a gente fala de
negócios é muito fácil né de enxergar
como a tecnologia ímpar que impacta
enfim a gente vive falando né sobre
empresas vão sobreviver ou não eu como é
que eu faço pra trazer tecnologia para
minha empresa e assim eu consigo
continuar lidera no mercado enfim mas a
verdade é que o impacto da tecnologia
ele vai muito além dos negócios então se
a gente pensa forma como a gente olha
para a saúde para transporte e educação
e para muitas outras áreas da nossa vida
a tecnologia tem um impacto direto e
muito grande e aí a gente pode até
pensar trazer como exemplo aqui uniu ea
moon que são dois blogs que esse blog é
uma combinação é de de uma uma pessoa
neodi algo orgânico com algo cibernético
então normalmente são pessoas que têm
vários implantes enfim
o grupo ou algo relacionado a isso e
essas duas pessoas
eles fizeram uma residência artística
num escritório da totvs e foi assim que
eu conheci a história deles e amon por
exemplo ela é dançarina artista e ela
resolveu implementar um chip em
implantar um chip que toda vez que
existe que tem um abalo sísmico em
qualquer lugar do mundo ela sente isso
no corpo dela
mas obviamente é tão sutil que é quase
como se ela incluísse que teve um abalo
sísmico porque seria muito horrível né o
dia inteiro de graça assim então
obviamente é uma coisa super a refinada
e sutil e união ele é daltônico então o
que ele fez foi implementar essa antena
que vocês conseguem ver na foto que é o
mantena aqui quando ele se depara com
alguma cor que ele não consegue
identificar essa antena faz um som então
ele passa a ouvir as cores que ele não
enxerga e acho que quando a gente olha
para esse cenário parece algo nessa e
meio distante ou talvez até meio extremo
e acho que gera uma certa expectativa é
do que vêem em pouco tempo o que vai
acontecer o que isso traz né
nos próximos anos e falando de
expectativa eu acho que se a gente eu
gosto sempre que eu falo de expectativa
eu lembro do tingüí que não sei se todo
mundo conhece mas é quem criou o world
wide web ou a w ou www www que acredito
que todos estejam familiares
familiarizados e é uma pessoa que criou
isso pensando em como as pessoas
conseguiriam compartilhar conhecimento
de uma forma mais simples e mais
democrática
então quando ele queria ele não pensa em
patente ao fechar o código e ficar
milionário com isso que eu acho que
aconteceria e sim ele decide deixar isso
aberto de um jeito que todo mundo
pudesse usufruir né do que ele criou e
com isso a gente começa a gente começa a
ver diversos cenários de expectativas
diferentes com relação ao impacto que a
internet vai ter no mundo por exemplo de
que a gente está criando um mundo
onde todo mundo pode entrar sem
privilégio ou preconceito relacionado à
raça poder econômico o local de
nascimento e isso foi dito pelo john
perry barlow que talvez alguns também
conheçam que é um dos fundadores da
electronic frontier foundation que é uma
das maiores ongs que trabalham com
direitos civis digitais
então é uma pessoa super renomado e
conhecida em 1996
essa é a leitura que ele tinha do que a
internet ea fazer com o mundo
então a gente vê que é meio geral a
expectativa de uma tecnologia que vai
diminuir desigualdades no mundo
existente que na época era bastante
desigual
só que acho que a internet também nos
ensina que a expectativa normalmente é
muito diferente da realidade e o que a
gente vê o seguinte tem um estudo da
unicef que conclui que a má distribuição
de internet pode estar criando novos
tipos de desigualdade não só existe às
vezes existentes
a gente vê que hoje em dia a 75% do
continente africano não tem acesso à
internet e que 34% dos brasileiros
também não e isso significa é 70 milhões
de pessoas
um estudo do banco mundial dizendo que a
internet está aumentando as
desigualdades já existentes ea gente vê
que a gente está vivendo num mundo onde
oito pessoas do planeta possuem tanta
riqueza quanto à metade mais pobre da
população mundial
oito pessoas têm tanta riqueza quanto 4
quanto quase 4 bilhões de pessoas
esse é o nosso mundo hoje dessas oito
pessoas metade delas são donos de
empresas de tecnologia e o próprio timbu
anos lhe poucos meses atrás volta
público e diz que a internet falhou
comunidade que ele sente que o propósito
inicial da criação dele foi totalmente
derrotado assim foi totalmente aconteceu
algo completamente diferente do que ele
esperava que acontecesse e ele próprio
criou uma organização para tentar
mitigar os impactos negativos que a
internet está causando
e acho que tudo isso nos traz sempre é
um pouco desse questionamento de nossa
mas a gente tem que ter medo a gente tem
que ser otimista e eu obviamente o
trabalho com tecnologia e não tenho a
menor dúvida do poder muito
transformador que a tecnologia tem acho
que isso é inegável é o que a gente pode
o quanto pode ser feito com um
ferramentas tecnológicas
só que acho que falta a gente trazer
outros pontos de vista para a mesa e
poder olhar o cenário inteiro poder
fazer um pouco que nenhum como eu vou me
ensinava sair da minha vivência e olhar
para o macro e acho que quando a gente
faz isso a gente vê muito sendo falado
sobre uma neutralidade nesta sobre uma
internet é neutra e uma tecnologia na
verdade que é neutra e que ela vai ser
bom ou ruim dependendo do uso que é dado
para ela e eu entendo esse raciocínio
mas eu penso um pouquinho diferente e eu
acho que esse pouquinho diferente faz
muita diferença
eu quero pra pra explicar isso trazer de
volta essa história que contei lá no
início da copa o din
então ela foi realmente uma máquina
extremamente importante para o
desenvolvimento da indústria como um
todo mas tenho mais uma partidinha dessa
história que eu não contei ainda nessa
época a escravidão já tinha sido
proibida nos estados unidos
só que o que acontece quando essa
máquina chega nas fábricas eo algodão
começa a conseguir ser né
separado da fibra da semente enfim de
uma forma muito mais rápida
a colheita do algodão já não dá conta de
né supre né a demanda da máquina ea
máquina fica ociosa o que é muito ruim
já que eu não estou fazendo tanto
dinheiro quanto poderia
e aí o que acontece é que inúmeros
estados dos estados unidos pessoas
negras voltam a ser escravizados para
poder colher em algodão e aí a pergunta
que eu faço essa máquina é boa é ruim ea
resposta que eu tenho pelo menos é que
tanto essa máquina
todas as tecnologias elas são elas nunca
são boas nem ruins mas elas
definitivamente nunca são neutras
elas são sempre ambíguas ou seja a mesma
tecnologia vai ser sempre boa e ruim
simultaneamente o grande problema disso
é que na minha visão
ela é sempre boa para um mesmo grupo de
pessoas e ruim por um outro mesmo grupo
e o que eu me pergunto é quando o que a
gente começa a usar a tecnologia para
diminuir esse abismo social e esse monte
de desigualdade que a gente vive
ao invés de usar a tecnologia
simplesmente para deixar um número
minúsculo de pessoas milionárias
obrigado
[Aplausos]